Okay?
I'm assuming yeah. Thank you everyone
for joining the session.
If you joined the previous session, we
are switching slightly the topic and
talking more about Gemini now, but I
have two slides about Gemini as well.
So, to make guest happy. I'm Patrick.
I'm a member of the technical staff at
Google DeepMind. I work on the Gemini
API and AI Studio. And today I want to
talk about any-to-any building native
multimodal agents. So, I want to talk
about multimodal understanding,
multimodal generation, real-time
interactions, and then also build an
example app together. So, at the end of
this session, you should be able to
build this for yourself, a little
notebook LM clone.
So, what does any-to-any mean?
These are all the capabilities you can
do with the Gemini API. So, there's a
lot of use cases this enables
because Gemini does not only understand
text, right? It's natively multimodal,
so you can also feed in code, image,
audio, video, and then some more like
URLs and also Google Search. And then it
can not only generate text, but now
we're also able to generate images,
speech generations, video generations,
function calls, and of course of course
code generation. So, yeah, this enables
a lot of really really cool stuff.
But, this
slide is
slightly
giving the wrong impression because
actually there are still different
models. It's not one multimodal model
yet. This is kind of a bigger vision
that we have at Gemini at Google
DeepMind to bring more of the generation
capabilities also into Gemini. But,
currently it looks a little bit like
this. This is an ugly slide, I know.
But,
yeah, we have the main Gemini model as
series right now Gemini 3, and it's able
to understand multiple modalities, but
it only outputs text. And then we have
different specialized native generation
models, for example, Nano Banana for
native image generation and speech
generation based on the main Gemini
models. And I want to talk about this in
a moment a little bit.
And also I mentioned Gemma here. Correct
me if I'm wrong, but it has allows text,
image, and video input, and the smaller
models also audio inputs. So, you can
also build multimodal agents locally.
Yeah.
So, I want to focus on on four things,
four models, the multimodal
understanding with Gemini, native image
generation, native speech generation,
and then also if we still have time a
little bit about the live API.
And then build something together or at
least give you the building blocks how
you can build this, a little notebook LM
clone. Who has used notebook LM before?
Almost everyone. Okay, so I don't think
I have to explain it.
But, yeah, you can feed in multiple
different sources,
and then the audio overview is pretty
popular where you can generate a podcast
to explain topics for you. And then also
infographics are pretty cool. So, we
want to build the same thing. And we
want to build this as an agent rather
than a workflow. So, this means that the
agent should be able to decide what to
create rather than where we hard code
the pipeline.
Here we are having a reasoning model
that can decide
what to create, and then it's hooked up
via tool calls or function calls, and
then calls the other specialized models.
Um
So, this is roughly how the the app or
the agentic architecture looks like. We
have the phase one for multimodal
understanding.
And then we have the phase two. This is
where we have the agentic loop where we
use Gemini as the reasoning model, and
it can then call different tools, and
these will then generate different
modalities for us. And then it acts in a
loop and reasons if we need more assets
or if it's good enough. And then in the
end we get text, speech, and
and infographics as an output.
And
yeah, I want to do this as an example
with the some learning about attention
is all you need paper. So, we want to be
able to feed in PDFs, images, videos.
This can be a lecture, for example, or
tutorial. And then voice memos. And
ideally we also want this cross-modal
understanding, right? That we can draw
information from all the different
sources together and make let them model
make connections.
And it's actually extremely easy with
Gemini to achieve this. This is
basically the code you need. Who has
built with the Google AI SDK before?
Half half almost half of the room. Yeah,
basically this is how you set it up. You
get your API key for free at ai.studio,
and then you install the SDK. We have it
available in different languages. And
then you can simply upload different
files. Like here we are uploading a PDF,
video, and an MP3 file. Or you can also
for smaller files directly use it as
inline data. And as a tip on the right
side I mentioned
Gemini API skill, so you don't have to
know this code now by heart. You can
just yeah
hook up your agent with the Gemini
skill, and then tell it um
to create this, and then it should know
how to work with the Gemini models.
Yeah, this is basically everything we
need. And then we call client models
generate content, and here we're using
Gemini 3 flash. And then we can put
everything together into the contents
list, and tell it for example analyze
all these resources, give it a little
bit more information what these
resources contain, and then it should
generate a summary.
And then a little bit of of practical
tips or nice-to-knows for for
understanding. You can also use it to
transcribe audio actually. Flash and
even the smallest ones, Flashlight, is
pretty good at transcribing audio. If
you just tell it in the prompt generate
a transcript of this file.
And it may be nice to know this for
audio. 1 minute of audio translates to a
1920 tokens. And Gemini has a token
limit of 1 million. So, if you do the
math, it translates to more than 9 hours
of content you can feed in audio
content. For video, it's roughly 1 hour.
But, there are
configurations you can tweak that give
you more control, and you can even feed
in longer audios.
Then you can tell it to
look at only different timestamps. So,
for example, only analyze from minute 5
to minute 15.
Um
And then yeah, you can use the file API
that easily lets you upload larger
files. You can even pass in URLs,
YouTube URLs directly. And what's also
nice to know is you can combine it with
context caching. This is built into the
API. This is especially useful if you're
loading longer files into Gemini and
doing repeated queries because then it
saves you 90% of the costs.
Um So, yeah, this is multimodal
understanding in a nutshell. So, here
doing a quick checkpoint. We're now able
to use Gemini to understand all these
different resources and generate a
summary.
Um
Actually, the timer is not working, so I
don't know how much longer I have. But,
I think
we are still a little bit good. So,
yeah, then the next phase is the the
multimodal generation part.
So, for this we're using the agentic
loop where we use Gemini
as the brain behind this, and we combine
it with function calling. I will show
you how to do this in a moment. And then
these function call the specialized
native generation models. And then it
can reason if these assets are enough or
if you need more.
And the way to do to use these
specialized models is also
basically the same code. Once you have
the SDKs, you call again client models
generate content. In this case, we're
using Gemini 3.5 flash image preview.
It's not the nicest model, but this is
actually Nano Banana 2, the more famous
model famous name for it. And then we
tell it to yeah create a picture. Or in
this case, we can it's pretty good at
creating infographics, which is pretty
cool. Just give it in your prompt create
an infographic.
And then it's creating these these nice
slide graphics for us. And similar for
text-to-speech, there we have a
text-to-speech model, which currently is
still based on Gemini 2.5. And you can
combine it with different
configurations. You can also do two
speaker
audio files. So, for example, this
podcast style.
And here is a nice
example if the sound works.
How does it work?
neural network architecture introduced
in a 2017 Google paper called Attention
is All You Need. That was a good example
of the text-to-speech model we have, but
then explains a transformer in only 2
minutes for you.
And
then the function calling like I
mentioned so basically to combine Gemini
with function calling or tool calling.
What you need to do is you create your
function declarations. So there you give
it a name and a description. This helps
the model to understand what this
function is used for.
And then also the different parameters.
So in this case we only want one string
which is then used for the prompt so the
detailed description of how the image
should look like.
And then you do the same for the audio
generation function. And then if you set
up your model call client models
generate content you you configure the
tools.
And then you also need to add this to
your prompt. So this is a small example
prompt an agent prompt
where you tell Gemini hey here's the
study we synthesized before from the
different modalities. And now you're a
research agent partner. Your job is to
enhance the study guide with multiple
materials. And then you do and you tell
it the two functions. So
decide which concepts are complex enough
to need a visual diagram. And for this
call generate image. And which sections
would benefit from an audio audio
summary. And for this call generate
speech.
And yeah this is basically everything
you need to set up the agentic function
calling for the multimodal generation
part.
And I also quickly wanted to touch on
why native generation matters. So we
call this native image generation models
for example because they are based on
Gemini. So all the training or a lot of
the training that goes into the main
Gemini models are now also available in
these models. And this allows a lot of
really really cool use cases because
these models understand the world. This
on the left side is for example I found
on Twitter and
example I really like from Nano Banana 1
where you can draw arrows on maps and
just tell it hey
create a picture of what you see here.
And since Gemini understands the world
here it's able to to correctly
create a picture of the Golden Gate
Bridge for you. And then on the right
side this is a nice example on the from
the educational space. So you can use
Nano Banana in this case it was Nano
Banana 2 to directly
correct your math homework for example
and create pictures with the corrections
because it understands math. It can even
generate code on images for you. So
there's lots of nice use cases.
And for the audio models these are
multilingual and they understand accents
and tone.
Hey up lads and lasses. We're getting
stuck into building these multimodal
agents today. No faffing about. Let's
just get them started so we can all nip
to the pub for a proper pint.
Was it a good British accent?
Yeah?
Anyone
speaking German here?
One two three. I have a Bavarian accent
because you can actually also tell it to
create different accents. Of course not
every accent in the world but still. So
here's one with a Bavarian accent.
Was it a good Bavarian accent?
So yeah I would say that's
pretty
Okay.
Yeah.
And yeah again it's a quick checkpoint.
We now know how to do on the
understanding part and the generation
part. And this is basically already the
the notebook LM clone. And now I quickly
wanted to mention now or we also have a
model for real-time interaction with it
via our what we call the live API. And
for this we have a very new model which
is also based on Gemini
Gemini 3.1 flash live. And we call this
an audio to audio model. So native
audio generation it's only one
architecture. Audio goes in and audio
goes out. So you no longer have this
cascaded pipeline with different models.
And this allows a lot of really really
cool natural sounding interactions. I
think I don't have time for a live demo
but you can try it at ai.studio/live.
And here is a quick video from one of
our colleagues Thor.
Um
Hey Gemini. You kind of How are you
today? started and start talking to it
and then you can also Hi. I'm doing
great.
I'm doing great. Thanks for asking.
Just enjoying the chat you know. And how
are things with you?
Um can you see me?
Well as plain as day. I see you there
with your short hair and beard wearing a
grand dark jacket over a blue shirt. But
yeah try it out for yourself at
ai.studio/live.
And I think that's almost it.
Yeah this is again how you can do it in
the code but there again we have a skill
for it that you can figure configure.
And this yeah now we are at all the
three checkpoints. And yeah the pattern
is transferable to every every other
field.
Um
And maybe a few shout-outs as well to
some other models. I'm not sure if
you've seen the keynote this morning
but we now have a multimodal embedding
model where you can combine all the
different modalities into one unified
vector space which allows applications
like multimodal search. And then again
you can go local with Gemma 4 and again
have this multimodal understanding. And
video for for image for video with
native audio. And so that's it. Thank
you and have fun building multimodal
agents.